it was a particular evening
and i had had a really really rough year
that year my father had died suddenly
and i was making six movies about
unsolved murders so it was a really
really rough subject i had a production
company
and so everything that could go wrong
went wrong that year until i reached
september the 9th because the first
phone call absolutely brought me to my
knees and that was my accountant saying
you're going to
you're going to be broke in 30 days
you've gone 2 million over budget on the
movies and i still had one and a half to
deliver and then i hung up the phone and
as i had the phone it rang again it was
my mother and he was in a really bad way
so those two phone calls
absolutely brought me to my knees
because i didn't feel that i could
solve either problem like i was so good
at fixing things but these two things my
mother was grief-stricken
because my father had died earlier in
the year and so these two things i could
not solve when i was 19 i ended up in a
really abusive relationship um which i i
now see is sort of like the catalyst for
my awakening in a way
there was at one point where
he had
hurt me and i was in the bathroom i had
locked myself in the bathroom
and i looked in the mirror and i could
hardly recognize myself but all of a
sudden it was as if the top of my head
opened up and just this message poured
in and it was just like shalina you're
going to be speaking on stage to women
about this one day like this is what
you're meant to be doing
and i saw myself doing that and i
remember actually telling him that i
said you know i had this vision the
other day that i'm actually going to
work with women who were in abusive
relationships or you know were in
harmful places in their lives and
and this is part of my path so i think
you should really get help because this
is going to be talked about starting at
the beginning my mum died when i was
seven my my dad went to work when i was
17 never came back he he passed on a
shipping disaster in england where the
boat capsized hundreds of people died it
was pretty
pretty horrific because it was all
covered on the news by virtue of the
event it wasn't like he was by himself
on a motorcycle or something like it was
a nationwide event an only child being
orphaned at 17 that was obviously quite
pivotal in ways that i didn't fully
understand what it did give me was the
glimpse of the isolation most recently
i'm about six months uh
in recovery from postpartum depression
anxiety and insomnia at the lowest point
suicidal
and i was about four months into my
record my my postpartum and that's when
it came on which is not typical usually
it comes on earlier i
was at the darkest moment of my life and
i've been through a lot of dark moments
you know i've been in sober recovery for
14 years i've remembered trauma but like
this scenario was by far rocked me to my
core
brought me to my knees
but i stayed
in constant contact with a higher power
of my own understanding i stayed in
constant communication with that inner
guidance system through prayer
and even though the prayers weren't
making it go away the prayers were
guiding me to the doctors the medication
the healers whatever it was that i
needed to get back to baseline i had
this big huge life change where you know
my mom passed away and they're going
through this huge breakup everything
kind of happened at the same time my mom
is you know was always so healthy and
when we found out we she had cancer she
was gone in six weeks and so it was just
like oh my god every anything and
everything can happen in this life and i
ended up you know moving out on my own i
went through this big breakup with my
partner at the time i became a single
mom and it was something like i never
thought was going to happen to me you
know again half of my family's from the
philippines where divorce is still
illegal like you just hit a breaking
point and something does change in a
moment it always changes in a moment and
it's up to you to get to that moment
so what can we do to get to that moment
with routines practices disciplines
how do we get there because there's got
to be there's always something that
leads up to it your breakdowns are just
going to keep getting bigger
until you wake the [ __ ] up and get the
lesson that the universe is sending i
mean
period
uh it took me a long time to see
that i had a
very
painful pattern of being drawn to
really big personality people who are
really fun and edgy and just like wow
like a shiny object
and then you know when you're having fun
with this kind of person and you're
laughing all the time and they're really
edgy and they start to realize oh my god
they're actually kind of mean to people
or they're they lie or they do this
now all of a sudden i get scared
because i don't know how to back away
and time and time and time and time like
i can go all the way back
to
uh
friends in elementary school to
uh a babysitter that i
once hired to
business uh associates back in the day
to like just they're there there they
are there they are there they are there
they are and it wasn't until i had a
massive issue happened with one of them
it was super painful
that made me go holy [ __ ]
this is a pattern
this person has been showing up in your
life since you were nine years old and
and so i just collapsed in despair and
that moment of collapsing in despair
was the moment where my life would
change forever
because my daughter
my adult daughter saw me
and just walked out and handed me this
book which was from 1910 and said read
this little help
and i mean
i've asked her since why did you give me
that book
and she's like i don't know you know she
just didn't know she was just and the
way that she gave it to me was almost
kind of
um robot like do you know like just uh
handing it
what's even weirder
is that with with the sky falling in
after the two phone calls is that
i read the book
right you made time for the book i just
sat down right there and then and i and
i opened it up and i started reading and
all my tears were hitting the pages the
ink was running and
90 minutes later i'd finished reading it
and oh my gosh
i just had the biggest biggest
realization of course the book was the
trigger and the book is called the
science of getting rich by wallace
wattles and it's available for free on
our website
if anybody wants to download it the
sacred dot tv it was
a year and a half ago where i first
spoke on stage about that exact moment
and it was really full circle for me um
so i sort of got that download really
early and then i still had to go through
all this other stuff and mess up a lot
in my relationships and
be on both sides of it you could say so
i feel like it's just been gathering
that wisdom
and then when i was 25-ish
i got married to somebody who was from
another country and um
we were best friends and i was like okay
well
we don't really want to be together long
term but even if we don't stay together
like i want you to be able to be here
and
so you know being a naive in
20-something we we got married and then
that all fell apart has very much ended
in deep deep betrayal um towards me
and um i lost everything in that process
everything all my money my business my
reputation like everything i was just
torn apart
but there was a really beautiful thing
that happened in that which was
all of the pain i was feeling i was also
getting all these flashbacks of my
childhood or
memories
of things that i kind of thought i had
worked through where i was like oh wow
this is not dealt with at all
and so i had this moment of realization
like all of this stuff that i'm feeling
it actually doesn't have anything to do
with him
like i don't need him to do anything i
don't need him to come back i don't need
him to fix it i don't even need him to
stop doing what he's doing
i just need to go get right with me and
my inner child and so then i met a
spiritual teacher and then i worked with
him for four and a half years in
transpersonal therapy course in miracles
junior shadow work
and and depth psychology so that was
sort of the catalyst so it's all been
it's all kind of come from
a lot of pain
but it really led me to a beautiful path
so so my experience of separation was
very visceral because it was literal in
terms of like i am by myself
it wasn't like i'm in a relationship
like a lot of people are they could even
be married but they feel lonely or they
feel isolated or they could have a
family but they feel somehow you know
discarded by the family so they feel
separated that way but they have a
family
i didn't have any of it so at the time
it was just very painful and i didn't
really know how to process certainly my
mum when i was seven but then in
hindsight i was like wow i think much of
it was so that i could get to the place
of really having such a profound
compassion
for every human being's ego which by
design is the experience of separation
so i had the visceral experience the
literal experience so that i really
could
fully relate when people feel like
they're not loved they're not good
enough they're not you know valued
whatever it is because those are i would
assert
aspects of the isolated ego but my quote
quote you know awakening was um just
over 20 years ago i was sitting in a
rent control apartment in santa monica
everything that i possessed in this 200
square foot space
and i'd gone through a breakup with a
girl who at the time in my understanding
of love was somebody that i loved but
she left me
and i sort of fell apart and couldn't
sleep and lost weight and i was calling
all my you know guy friends like how do
i get it back the reason that it was the
darkest moment was because
it was my
my first taste of really understanding
what mental illness is
wow i've while i've been in sober
recovery for a long time and i struggled
with addiction when i was in my 20s and
remembered you know dissociated traumas
and
those scenarios in my life
were probably
considered mental illness from the
standpoint of being depressed or having
you know having to to anesthetize
through drugs or alcohol but i'd never
experienced the type of mental illness
that was causing panic attacks that was
causing insomnia that was causing
me to say on mother's day i want to kill
myself
and here i was i authored seven
self-help books and i was suicidal uh so
i'm so deeply grateful for that dark
bottom because now i can speak to mental
illness with so much conviction and
authority and
and most importantly authenticity
and i can see how when people come to me
my audiences and for years they'd say i
i'm depressed or i have this uh you know
biochemical issue and my response was
probably part of the stigma i would say
things like well you know just meditate
more and
but without the level of awareness of
where these kinds of conditions can take
you i wasn't in a position to be able to
speak to medication and how you could
use medication to go deeper on your
spiritual path if you needed to and to
really honor that side of the
conversation i think that when my mom
passed i looked at everything in my life
and just became like it's like i woke up
i just feel like i hit rock bottom
danica i would go and like cry in the
closet i look at everything and one of
the and then i just started to rebirth
and one of the things that came out of
that is saluna so when you think about
what is saloon it means the sun and the
moon so it means like the light and the
dark so i started looking at everything
differently like don't run away from
hard feelings don't think it's just
about the food it's this idea of
everything's all together in the pot and
we are whole and everything's in our
part of us too so you know the dark is
where seeds start to germinate and grow
um and shamans talk about the dark being
necessary for transformation you go into
the dark you go into those hard feelings
and then you grow i really sort of fell
apart
i had these these like annoying
questions like will i see her again is
she dating somewhere else
where is she will i have love like that
ever again like all of these questions
that were just like literally quite
unanswerable until the moment where i
got the answer to all of them
and it was so cathartic and it was so
profound profound that the answer was
three words i don't know
and at that moment like will i see her
again where is she is she with someone
else will i have love like that whatever
the question was
the accurate answer at that moment given
time like literally was i don't know and
when i hit when i got that i realized
wow that's the nature of life like i
really got the fabric of the universe in
terms of the linear progression of time
through human being is complete
uncertainty we don't know what's going
to happen the ego by virtue of the fact
that it's living within a container of
fear is always trying to figure it out
like because it wants to survive so
you've got this complete contradiction
now of life is uncertain but the ego
wants certainty and therein lies
suffering so right at that moment i
realized not only the answer to all my
questions that gave me access
to the actual fabric of life which is
uncertainty but for the first time in my
life i was totally okay with it
i hope you're not as stubborn as i am
because it took me 41 years
to
see the lesson
about
toxic behavior that i was attracted to
and toxic behavior that i engaged in in
my own people pleasing
and inability to draw a line and like
distance myself or end relationships
that really didn't work
and i know they don't work because i get
that feeling in my stomach and then i
see myself twisting myself in knots so
as to not upset somebody who's basically
crazy
and i'm now like turning all around to
not upset the person that is you know
i'm afraid of their reaction
because they're not regulated in terms
of their emotions and so i it took me a
long time and so i want every i want you
to understand if you're listening to
this that if you're in a frustrating
situation i want you to ask yourself
number one
when in my life have i felt like this
before
and who has made me feel like this what
situations have made me feel like this
and start listing them and when you see
one you'll see another and then another
and then another and then there's that
boss and then there's a situation
and then
you'll ask yourself
[Music]
what is it that i'm doing that is having
me
show up in this situation again and so i
identified kind of the the personality
pattern that i was drawn to fun
unpredictable like oh your life of the
party like kind of like just whoo this
feels fun and this feels on edge because
i can't predict
what's going to happen because this
person's so entertaining only to realize
holy [ __ ] the same thing that drew me in
is what's staring me now and turning me
into a massive people pleaser that makes
me go crazy if you can identify that
then you ask yourself what is the lesson
that life is trying to teach me i drove
to my mother straight away the next
morning and i told her everything i
discovered so i got her all set
and and a whole new world had opened up
for her and then i went back continued
with the research and in january
um of 2005 i walked into my team and i
said we're going to make um and i it
wasn't a documentary at that stage or a
movie or i didn't know what it was we're
going to make something that will change
the world
[Music]